so in my view
rape has become decriminalised rape has
always been
a difficult crime to prove in court but
the criminal justice system
has now reached a level of crisis we're
probably seeing the lowest volume of
convictions
against the highest levels of reports
that we ever have
in the year ending march 2020 99
of rapes reported to police in england
and wales resulted
in no legal proceedings against alleged
attackers
i was absolutely certain that that was a
true account of rey
but there's been an acquittal literally
the first thing i said to her mum was
that i want to die
i didn't i didn't want to live anymore
with convictions
at the lowest levels on record we face
an uncomfortable question
has rape become the perfect crime i
wouldn't recommend that someone
report their rape case
my name is bonnie turner and i'm here
today
because i was raped he
and i had known each other for two and a
half years
and we had started a consensual sexual
relationship with each other
i was staying with him and at some point
during the night
he i became aware that he was
on top of me
and he was trying to penetrate me
and he couldn't because i was completely
dry
and i remember hearing him
spit on his hand he
then started to rape me
i wanted to move i wanted to scream i
wanted to
yeah i i wasn't able to do anything and
i was completely frozen
i actually thought i was having a
nightmare i
kept on thinking to myself move use your
voice move scream
i eventually i could and i was able to
shove his body off me with both
i used both hands and shoved his
shoulders and i managed to shout stop
my name's sam thompson and i'm a
survivor of male rape
i recently moved to manchester with my
girlfriend at the time
she landed her dream job and i was
pursuing my dream of becoming
a professional dj and we decided to go
on a night out we uh
went for a few drinks just in pubs and
stuff and then like many of us do
i was chatting to a group of strangers
and just discussing
anything i can't remember the
conversation but i remember thinking
they're all right people
the group kind of fizzled down i guess
people had to go home it would
have been the early hours of the morning
at this point and
left me with just the just two people
and they offered if i wanted one more
drink i thought there's no harm it's
already ridiculate
it was after i'd had that drink that
everything became
really hazy i couldn't work out
whether i had been spiked whether i was
just extremely drunk
i remember i remember them removing my
clothes
and i remember not doing anything about
it i was just froze
and then i just remembered them taking
it in turns to
rape me for a number of hours i don't
really remember how it finished
and i don't remember masses of the
experience
and i don't even remember whether i fell
asleep or just
came round and left
it started to hit me like the shock kind
of came with me all at once
as i was walking back to my flat and it
was just before i got back to my flat
sort of over a bridge near where i lived
and then sort of had the feeling that
i couldn't live with this didn't know
what to do and that i wanted to end my
life there
and then
[Music]
in the wake of jimmy savile revelations
and the metoo movement
the number of rapes reported to police
in england and wales
has tripled since 2012 but victim's
bravery
is not being rewarded in the last three
years the number of rapes
prosecuted and convicted has collapsed
i did continue to see him for three more
nights he was in london
and on the third night in the middle of
the night i woke up
sobbing my heart pounding sweating
profusely
he left london and
i thought i will never see him again he
had continually tried to contact me on
facebook messenger
and i had ignored all of the messages
until two weeks later and i just said
look i don't want to talk to you
it's one thing to gently wake your lover
up in the middle of the night
and if they respond positively to then
take things from there
it's another thing to forcibly penetrate
someone when they're fast asleep
as you did with me and much to my
surprise
he responded saying i know
i'm so sorry i made a huge mistake uh
i should never have tried from the
beginning i realized too late that you
were asleep
when i got that message i thought if i
don't report this to the police
it will just eat me up forever i thought
this is
evidence we went to the police station
i was then asked to go and sit in a room
i was told that i couldn't stay with my
girlfriend
time or my friend when they took my
story again i didn't feel like
i was believed they were asking
questions that i seemed to be ridiculous
asking me if i'd ever had a male sexual
encounter asking me my sexuality
asked me if i've ever cheated on my
girlfriend all things which are
completely irrelevant to what the thing
that was that i was reporting
and i was still in the clothes i still
hadn't had a shower i could still smell
these two strangers on me but they asked
me not to shower
or to have a bath so that they could get
as much forensic evidence as possible
you feel dirty as it is but being able
to smell other people
on you it just added to the pain it's
undeniable um percentages aside
from report to conviction um
we're probably seeing the lowest volume
of convictions
against the highest levels of reports
that we
we ever have it's something that police
chief constables up and down the country
worry about perpetrators not being
convicted
potentially means the public generally
less safe
and because it means that future victims
won't come forward
in the year ending march 2020 over 55
000 rapes were reported to police
but fewer than 1 500 people were
convicted
this is the lowest number of rape
convictions on record
and the problem may be even worse rape
is an extremely underreported crime
the latest figures from the ons estimate
they're up to 107
000 victims of rape every year in
england and wales
nine out of ten are women rape is a
serial offense
so we've convicted a thousand fewer each
year
that suggests that there are people who
shouldn't be free who are free
people who are rapists we'll carry on
raping until they're stopped and they
don't think they're going to be stopped
at the moment
i've experienced prosecuting cases where
i was
absolutely certain that that was a true
account of rape
but there's been an acquittal where
there is a rape
reported and particularly a rape against
the background of a previous consensual
sexual relationship people are asking
the question
has that been made up whereas in fact
there is no evidence to support the
contention
that rapes are more likely to be made-up
crimes as opposed to
any other offence it was
january 2018 that the
cps made their decisions to not
prosecute the man who raped me
they said it was because of lack of
evidence
and i was devastated if
my case isn't prosecuted like what
chance does
you know the vast majority of cases
don't have evidence like that
we asked the crown prosecution service
why they did not proceed with bonnie's
case
in response they said we concluded there
was no realistic prospect of conviction
miss turner then applied for a judicial
review where the high court held that
the decision
was properly reasoned on the evidence
probably two and a half months after the
actual event itself
i had a phone call completely out of
blue to say that they were taking no
further action
i i completely devastated i just didn't
understand i had suspicions that i
didn't
i wasn't believed throughout all this
and the police were just following the
procedure and i put myself through
something
again that was quite traumatic all with
the idea that i was going to at least
you know be able to have my day in court
and
and gain a prosecution for what happened
but that was just taken away from me
the greater manchester police told sky
news in line with normal procedure
mr thompson's case was referred to the
gmp's
serious sexual offences unit but failed
to meet
the evidential test so in my view
rape has become decriminalised i don't
think that's an exaggeration
if someone wants justice in their
individual sort of case
i wouldn't recommend that someone
report their rape case
and i don't i don't want to have to be
in a position to say that
in 2019 the cps conducted their own
inspection
into falling rape convictions and found
a criminal justice system
under resource close to breaking point
was to blame
because of austerity there are fewer
detectives
dealing with bigger caseloads
some of those case loads in this this
are more complex
and they have all that material attached
to them um
so investigations are taking a lot
longer so resources
are an issue but they're not just an
issue for policing um
austerity has seen fewer prosecutors who
were also dealing with
bigger caseloads we're also seeing
increased numbers of victims reporting
so the demand
is increasing at the same time the
resources are becoming more stretched
a government spokesperson told sky news
we are conducting a full review of the
criminal justice system's response
recruiting 20 000 more police and giving
85 million to the crown prosecution
service
but a coalition of women's rights groups
say an intentional change in rape
prosecution policy
is to blame for the falling convictions
the end violence against women coalition
believes the crown prosecution service
secretly changed their policy in 2017.
effectively raising the bar for
prosecution by weeding out weaker cases
and only prosecuting rock solid cases
which were likely to win
in july 2020 the court of appeal
overturned a high court ruling
and granted a full judicial review
against cps rape charging policy
which will take place early next year
she's part of the long
term drop frankly
is the only word in rape prosecutions by
the cps who changed their
policy about how to prosecute cases
in 1617 but if you only take a few cases
then you don't convict a lot of people
and that's what's happened this is a
clear policy by the cps which frankly
needs to be reversed and it needs to be
reversed
today a cps spokesperson told sky news
there has been no change of approach in
cps prosecutions of rape
in every case referred to us we will
prosecute whenever our legal test is met
no matter how challenging it is the
court of appeal last month decided that
other procedural aspects of the end
violence against women's claim
should be the subject of a full hearing
which will be argued in due course
it's a very disturbing case that the
jury here at the old bailly are having
to sit through
if a rape victim's case makes it as far
as the courtroom
they often feel they themselves are on
trial
she was in tears at one point when the
defense was suggesting
that actually this wasn't rape that this
was consensual sex
because society as a whole still
believes rape myths our juries do too
consistency had never been a feature
of the complainant's evidence long
before
she entered the witness box defence
teams will often make use of these myths
to discredit victims and cast doubt in a
jury's mind
it might seem embarrassing to show a
pair of thongs
here in this incongruous setting of the
dog
how do you think a right victim or a
woman feels he should have
conquered the setting of her underwear
being shown in the court
when you are asking a jury to be sure
of guilt it has to be said that it
doesn't take
very much therefore in order to knock
the credibility
of the complainant a juror feeling
almost
certain or that that man in the dock has
probably done it it is not enough
thinking about perhaps some of the
central themes
that have been used by the defense in
the trial
they have been based on no screaming no
shouting
could have protected herself there were
other people in the house
would she really have not you know would
she really have spent the night
after she'd been raped in that bedroom
why didn't she go
running out of the house at the time you
know she must not be telling the truth
they expected that they would scream
and they would claw and they would fight
back with everything they had
but their survival mechanism in their
brain
made them submit so that they would walk
out of that incident
yes raped and psychologically scarred
but alive
[Music]
for many victims there is a huge mental
cost in reporting rape
to a criminal justice system that feels
stacked against them
four or five months after the event
itself i'd effectively worked myself
into the ground
i'd walked into the office i'd sat down
at my desk i was there before
everybody else and i just burst out in
tears
i couldn't work out why i couldn't cope
i didn't understand where this feeling
had come from
so i went out to my car before everyone
else arrived and i hid in the car park
effectively
i uh phoned my mum
i found her because i didn't know who
else to speak to um
and i i literally the first thing i said
to her mum was i want to die
and i didn't i didn't want to live
anymore
and i didn't understand what life was
anymore
and and that was a very horrible
conversation for me and her i think
and it was during that conversation and
that she made me promise
that i would at least try having therapy
it's an incredibly long and lonely road
it's really really hard
really hard um
you know many times i've you know i i
have felt suicidal many times
i wanted to die and
you know i think my main reason for
wanting to
wave anonymity is
because i feel very so strongly i have
nothing to be ashamed about and
the burden of keeping it a secret was
just killing me
i'm a smart capable person
with so much to to give
and yet i've been unable to work because
yeah i've been unable to go back to
full-time work because of this
[Music]
it's a waste of my energy and talent
it's a waste of my potential
and i'm just one person
you